No, let's just sit on the dock.
Oh...no!
This is not okay!
You guys can go through
a lot emotionally.
And then you bring it back
to the complete reset of
game on.
Tonight we have
rigatoni bolognese.
You got rigatoni bolognese
with no parmesan.
Guess what? I'm your
chief stew now.
You can't be too boujee.
This is how you do it.
Oh my gosh.
Uh, yeah.
Oh my...
Are you ready for this wedding day?
Oh my god.
Woo! We got married, bitches!
So thankful. Look at this rainbow!
We might be competing
for the same girl.
Apparently you kissed Zee.
We kissed last night.
What? No, we kissed last night.
Boat romances–they're dangerous.
This is what happens when I'm single.
The lazy susan is being ridden...
hard.
Keep the line out of the water please.
To lead people is to invest in them.
Amazing, thanks so much.
It's up to you.
Right now I'm pissed off with you.
I don't care. I'm, like, leaving.
Hey mom, I'm quitting this boat.
That's an incident report, Malia.
I'm not a chief officer.
I don't give a f---.
You should've come to me,
that he was hurt.
His blood pressure's really high,
he has chest pains,
he needs to go to the hospital.
Red on deck! Red on deck!
This is gonna pass, I promise.
If we're not challenged
then we won't grow.
Woah, what's going on in there?
If you f--- up, it's on me!
Everybody's being so
f------ dramatic!
Stop the f------- noise!
Stop being a kiss ass!
F--- off!
Yes! Woo!